And
is there a West that has a policy established
to provoke such a
war.
This is work and
this is the ground. But I say this number in light areas,
you are doing it wrong
Russia is not a country to be taken lightly At the
moment, shut up or cut off the natural gas
These prices have risen all of a sudden in Europe
Yes, now everyone is brooding. We
will increase them a little this winter.
What did you not think about,
if you have such an important other person, we should have thought about them before,
someone says that I
gave such financial support to Ukraine, I
gave such support. So where is
this money
Yes, this is just a word,
I hope we are doing the translations correctly.
subscribe Yes
this is also troublesome
and
weapons are said to be sent How
much of a hurd  If there is, they are sending these scraps to
Ukraine.